sherry is with us in Springfield
Illinois hi sherry how are you okay
thank you for taking my call today I'm
the new litter and I'm thrilled to be
able to talk to you I'm honored to talk
to you how can I help
so my daughter's 18 and she can be
graduating this year and she wants me to
pay for a third of her college her dad
promised her that I would do that it's
my ex-husband and they really don't have
that kind of money and I missed how your
excellent I missed how your ex-husband
gets to make promises for you I yeah I
don't know why he thinks it's okay but
he keeps doing that yeah well he can
jump in the creek he didn't get two
sentence equations that's why he's known
as ex mister who he wants to take me to
court to make me pay for her college and
he wants me to pull the money out of my
retirement and the divorce decree
require this no it didn't
well then Ted let's go to court and by
the way while were in court I'm going to
countersue him for about 63 things and
take his house it's time you've been
getting punched by this guy a long time
he is you know no way he sets the tone
of this discussion no way so what I'm
going to do if I'm in your shoes is
number one I'm going to hire an attorney
that's so mean that even I don't like
him so he completely guts everything in
your ex's life until he shuts this crap
down number two I'm gonna sit down with
said daughter and say daughter we don't
have the money we love you we're going
to be your biggest cheerleader we're
going to help you with some things and
let me just tell you sherry you needed
the first thing you need to do just what
Rachel and I were talking about in those
other segments you've got to be very
careful that she chooses a school that
she can afford and you can afford to
help her with out of your income what's
your household income well I'm on my own
and I get 64,000 okay
right and you have other children I have
other children and unfortunately I have
a lot of that too okay and how many
other children do you have
just one other okay and how old are they
she's going to be 15 oh good we're going
to countersue him on extra
child support then since he just wants
to go back and redo the whole divorce
decree okay yeah I want to double his
child I want double of child support and
how do you afford the attorney though I
want to have the attorney just go after
him for fun let you know you take this
to an attorney your attorney is going to
be just salivating over the chance to
get at this guy this is so absurd it's
unbelievable you have a settled divorce
decree we have a single mom deeply in
debt and this guy wants to go back and
to have her cash out her retirement to
pay for the kids college that's just
freaking idiocy a judge on lunch this
guy in the next week if you get in front
of him you know unfortunately Illinois
kind of been doing you know setting the
precedents were there you know forcing
divorced parents to pay for their kids
college education and I'm a little
concerned about that I'm not going back
and undoing divorce decrees that it
might not that might be the case in
going into a divorce decree that they're
asking them to do that but they're not
going to go back on a years old divorce
decree and undo it I just I don't
believe it I mean you know so you're
living in a lot of fear here sherry and
you know I'm trying to get you mad
that's what I'm trying to do and you
need to sit down with your little
daughter and say baby doll you're going
to the school you can afford because you
don't have the money and unless Daddy
Warbucks over here wants to write checks
you don't have the money and you know
it's an if it's not in the divorce
decree no you're not cashing out your
retirement to do it no no we're not
doing that that's crazy talk this kid
needs to go to school she can work while
she's in school she needs to get
scholarships and grants and she needs to
go to school she can afford and you need
to roll up your sleeves and get on a
budget and help yourself get out of that
to be able to do those things I'm going
to help you do that you hold on I'll
have Kelly pick up we're going to send
you a copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover but you need representation and
you really need to get mad about this
this guy's been driving the fear bus for
you long enough
this is I'm mad just thinking about it
and I'm not even up there I'm not around
it it's something you know I'm ready
just unbelievable unbelievable
thanks for the call so here's the thing
the inmates don't run the asylum and if
the inmates are running the asylum at
your house if your kids are telling you
what to do you don't have a financial
problem not in her case our case she's
got an ex involved okay but you folks
out there listen the reason we have a
student loan crisis is we didn't have
parents that walked up beside their kids
and kicked their little butts and said
no you're not going to school you can't
afford no we're not going over there and
go a hundred thousand dollars of student
loan debt so you can get a degree in
left handed puppetry no we're not doing
that no that's called parenting folks
and in Sherry's case she's got a parent
both the kid and her ex apparently this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show if you didn't know
I actually have my own YouTube channel
so I had two videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget